halloween 2 would literally pick up
right where the original left off but
that would not prevent it from
subjecting the story to some major
changes like some lore and motivation
for the mysterious masked antagonist
police find the word samhain or as
loomis says it champagne written on a
chalkboard at the elementary school the
significance is only briefly explained
by michael's psychiatrist dr loomis he
mentions that it's a celtic word meaning
lord of the dead that the festival of
samhain signified the end of song but
the meaning and connection to michael
myers and the overall message of
halloween 2 goes much deeper than that
it actually refers to a gaelic festival
marking the end of the harvest season
and the beginning of the darker half of
the year in the northern hemisphere it
is observed starting on the evening of
october 31st and ending in the evening
of november 1st much like michael's
rampage in this movie it begins on
halloween night and carries over into
the first day of november early
literature says that samhain was
celebrated with the opening of ancient
burial mounds which were seen as portals
to the other world which may have been
opened with bonfires and sacrifices
maybe meyer's defeat at the end of the
movie is symbolic for its connection to
these saowan festivals it is believed
that over time sauhan merged with other
cultural celebrations eventually
becoming halloween as we know it today
so it may come as no surprise that this
word may be the key to understanding
everything else in the undertones of the
original halloween sequel for my entire
analysis stick around to the end of this
video this video is sponsored by better
health
six gunshots would not be enough to keep
michael myers down just as dozens of
angry mothers would not be enough to
stop me for making another episode of
things you missed once again i'm joined
by youtube's resident halloween expert
jimmy champagne or as dr loomis would
pronounce it jimmy samhain if that's how
he says it i don't even want to imagine
how he'd spell it last time i broke down
the psychosexual subtext of the 1978
original so in this episode i'll
introspect the 1981 follow-up halloween
2 the first of many attempts to create a
direct sequel writer director john
carpenter initially wasn't interested in
continuing the story of michael myers
but then he said screw it i do like
money so he returned to produce and
write the screenplay oh and he also
decided to collaborate on the score so
directing duties would initially fall on
rick rosenthal but carpenter didn't like
what he came up with so he re-shot some
scenes and then he still didn't like the
finished product listen jimmy i'm not
going to get into the drama but i am
going to get in to the things you missed
[Music]
the opening of this film takes us back
to that fateful halloween night in 1978
and we fade in backed by the song mr
sandman by the chordae we hear the
lyrics mr sandman bring me a dream this
is the first of many references in this
movie to the idea of dreams and the
unconscious mind mr sandman is a myth
from european folklore and serves as a
stand-in for another mythological man
the boogeyman an alias that is commonly
used to refer to michael myers in the
first movie what's the boogie man
as a matter of fact
it was the lyric specifically says mr
sandman bring me a dream throughout the
movie lori is terrified of going to
sleep perhaps because some part of her
subconscious mind knows that her dreams
are where she'll see her brother and
nemesis michael myers we do see a
glimpse of one of those dreams when she
dozes off at one point at the hospital
though it's unclear if she made the
connection about who this mysterious boy
actually is but one way or another she
seems terrified of the idea of seeing
the backs of her eyelids ever since her
encounter with him it's the first thing
she tells the ambulance emt and she
reiterates it for the doctor no don't
put me to sleep and there's even a
deleted scene where she uses sheer
willpower to keep herself awake she
awake dr mixture gave her a double
bullet she didn't keep her eyes open
she's made out of steel she actually
falls asleep eyes open when the
medication fully kicks in a testament to
just how much she wanted to avoid seeing
that dream at all cause the beginning of
the movie takes us back to the final
five minutes of the original with a
couple of shots giving us a new
perspective on those events in a way
this was a taste of things to come rick
rosenthal would go to extreme lengths to
shoot this movie in the same style as
john carpenter's halloween and what
better warm-up exercise is there than
adding shots to an already existing
scene this is followed by a long pov
shot of michael myers spying on the
neighborhood which is of course a direct
callback to the intro shot of the
original halloween where we see the
world through young michael meyer's eyes
both scenes feature him looking through
windows sneaking inside and then
stealing a knife all while no one seems
to notice that he's there both scenes
are also important from a filmmaking
standpoint because one takes are
notoriously expensive and challenging to
get right so a little movie like
halloween 2 nailing it as hard as it
does really helped it to stand out from
the growing pool of competitors and that
pool was growing extremely quickly
michael looks in on mr and mrs elrod's
house no not that mrs elrod mr elrod is
watching dr dementia's horror movie
marathon a continuation of what lindsay
wallace and tommy doyle were seen
watching in the first one we continually
see this on tvs throughout the night
whether it's george romero's night of
the living dead or the 1955 horror film
dementia a movie involving a woman
caught in a nightmare cycle that deals
with the horror of the subconscious kind
of like how laurie feels that she's
trapped in an inescapable nightmare with
michael which affects her so badly she's
mortified at the idea of going to sleep
when i covered the original movie one
symbol that i pointed out time and time
again was the use of bed sheets we were
always seeing michael through these
sheets and i interpreted that as part of
this metaphor for his tendency to go
after these teens that were trying to go
to bed with one another there is one
hookup couple that michael takes out in
halloween 2 which may be the most brutal
scene in the whole franchise but the
main theme of this film if i had to pick
just one thing is the idea that michael
is this never-ending bad dream in that
sense the bed sheet motif still works
now being given a different meaning it's
associated with a dream where lori
discovers that she's related to michael
an idea that festers in her subconscious
but her conscious mind doesn't want a
face one constant in nearly all of john
carpenter's projects from the time is
the use of the actress nancy loomis
she's the woman who played annie in the
original halloween but her death in that
movie doesn't stop her from appearing a
few times in the sequel i'd say chances
are pretty slim you didn't miss when
annie's body was brought out of the
house and identified by her father but
you probably didn't notice that she
plays sally the girl on the other end of
the phone telling her friend about
what's going on in haddonfield didn't
you hear
hear about what some girl got killed
it's on the radio while there are still
plenty of halloween one callbacks to
discuss there's also a potential look at
the future of the franchise in the form
of one seemingly random side character
[Music]
do you find that you're not happy or
something is blocking you from reaching
your maximum potential in life it's time
for you to get some help some better
help better help is a professional
therapy service securely operated online
no more going into the office in person
no more sitting on the couch like this
which is what i assume happens at these
things you'll connect to a worldwide
network of over 20 000 therapists who
are guaranteed to be licensed
professionals you can easily log into
your account anytime to send a message
to your therapist and you'll get timely
and thoughtful responses you can also
schedule your weekly session via phone
call or video call that means you're
going to be saving money on gas and
sessions are already more affordable
than your traditional therapy with the
couch imagine if michael myers used
better health how much better things
might have gone i guarantee your better
help doctor will not try to shoot you
six times and five six shots into me
just got up and walked away visit
betterhelp.com that's better h-e-l-p and
join over one million people taking
charge of their mental health as a cz's
world viewer you get 10 off your first
month just click the link in the
description and betterhelp.com
shortly before lori's ambulance arrives
at the hospital we see a mother taking
her swashbuckling son into the emergency
room he's bleeding profusely from the
mouth and when he drops his towel we see
why a huge razor blade is jammed into
his guns this calls back to an urban
legend about tempered halloween candy i
remember when i was a kid my parents
would always have to inspect my
trick-or-treating hall to look out for
any rappers that might have been altered
in fear of a malicious neighbor possibly
poisoning or putting foreign objects
into the candy that's the implication
here michael myers is not the only evil
in hatton field long time halloween fans
know that michael wasn't intended to be
a recurring character john carpenter and
deborah hill plan to make it an
anthology series about various scary
stories all taking place on halloween
nights that's why halloween 3 has almost
no relation to the first two movies this
pirate costume kid almost seems to
foreshadow halloween 3 which spoiler
alert features an evil company's plot to
harm trick-or-treaters with so much of
this movie trying to match what happened
in the past this one character looks
towards halloween's future soon after
we're introduced to karen who is on her
way out of a halloween party in true
care and fashion she has a little bit of
a public freak out roll it
i'm never going to another halloween
party as long as i live especially not
at stevie mathis house this is our first
crew reference easter egg because steve
mathis is the electrician on this
movie's credits the only other one that
i can say definitely exists is in the
staff locker room at the hospital where
one of the lockers is labeled cummings
which has got to be a self nod by set
decorator peg cummings in order for
director rick rosenthal to fully immerse
us in the world of halloween there are
many specific callbacks to specific
moments within the first halloween movie
like how karen suggests her friend gets
a ride home from a halloween party from
a guy named eddie lee to which she
responds he's in russellville you might
also remember that the head and field
graves keeper mentions a town called
russellville in the first movie i
remember over in russellville on charlie
bold about 15 years ago when looking at
the news coverage of the murders on
orange grove avenue one of the emt's bud
makes this comparison it looks like a
goddamn homecoming it's a really
interesting choice of words because one
of the main plot points in the original
halloween regarded lori and who she
would choose to go to the homecoming
dance with well you could ask dick
baxter he'd go out with you
i'd rather go with ben tramer ben tramer
also makes an appearance in halloween
too or at least it's heavily implied
that the masked kid who gets slammed by
a police car was trammered yeah i'm
worried about bennett tramer he isn't
home yet yeah and he left the party at
10. you're just gonna brush past the
fact that the cop who just hit ben
tramer going 50 miles per hour gets out
of his car and says i didn't even see
him like you can't even give him the
benefit of the doubt on that one that
part is pretty funny if you're looking
out for it and i just love how the cop
basically goes out of his way to hit the
kid his body is totally burned up but
the forensic dentist also seems to think
that the victim is probably around
tremor's age on a night that feels like
it can't get any worse for lori strode
michael myers is indirectly responsible
for the death of her biggest crush
halloween has become the nightmare that
she can't wake up from then there's the
security guy garrett when we first meet
him he's reading a newspaper let's zoom
in on the headline here a dead ex-con
with six bullets in him will float this
probably refers to the lung flow test an
autopsy procedure that can help
pathologists determine the true cause of
death but what i'm more interested in
here is six bullets as you probably know
if you've seen the movie dr loomis
loaded michael with six bullets at the
conclusion of halloween in the doyle
house he proceeds to bring this up
whenever possible tell the [ __ ] if i
shot him i shot him six times i shot him
six times and fired six shots into me
couldn't have shot him six times you
think i'm lying sheriff speaking of
loomis there's also a scene where he and
the police discover that michael broke
into the elementary school that's where
they discover the samhain graffiti that
i mentioned earlier when they enter the
classroom they come across a childlike
drawing of a family of four with a knife
stuck into the sister obviously we're
led to believe that this represents
judith the sister that michael stabbed
in the opening of the first movie but we
later find out in the infamous twist
that laurie is michael's other sister
and this drawing shows that's the reason
he's coming after her if you look
closely you'll see what appears to be
another figure laying in the grass
colored in red i'm guessing that's
supposed to be judith and this is lori
who michael is threatening with the
knife the bigger question i have is
who drew this have michael's art skills
not progressed since age six due to his
incarceration in the sanitarium are we
supposed to believe that he made this
drawing in kindergarten and it's just
been filed away at the school somewhere
ever since or maybe it's just another
kid's drawing that he repurposed to send
his own message just don't even think
about it things will be better for you i
promise to be honest i have a lot of
questions about this movie like how did
the media find out about the babysitter
murders before the sheriff of the town
why does loomis put his face so close to
lori when he's asking if she's okay i'm
sorry i love you are you all right
that's so weird and why are there no
holes in michael's mask after laura
shoots him in the face are we supposed
to believe that both of those shots went
perfectly into the eye holes michael is
21 years old in this movie it's even
called out by dr loomis at one point so
why do the credits say michael myers age
23 they actually made the same mistake
in the first movie but if you do the
math he is 21 not sure how that happens
why does michael's mask look so funny
from a low angle was this entire thing
just an elaborate ruse by jimmy to get a
lap dance from lori strode man you can't
live with them you can't live without
them yeah i don't think that's how the
saying goes help her out lloyd women
can't live with them
can't live without them words of wisdom
the other question i've always had about
this movie comes up in the third act
when loomis marion chambers and the
state marshal show up at the hospital
not realizing that lori is injured in
the parking lot i always found it
pointless how she waits until after
they've gone inside to scream for help
but in analyzing this movie the scene
fits in with the bad dream theme that's
been established not being able to find
your voice totally sounds like something
that would happen in a nightmare i can
even remember having dreams like that as
a kid and then waking up to find myself
mouthing the words with the dry throws i
think the line that ties this movie's
themes together the best comes when
loomis explains the rituals of samhain
in order to appease the gods the druid
priests held fire rituals
prisons of war criminals the insane
animals
were
burned alive in bastards it is
interesting that when he brings up
rituals he specifically mentions burning
alive because as we all know that's
michael meyer's fate in this movie at
least for now and that iconic shot of
michael myers burning might be yet
another direct reference to the thing
from another world which was referenced
very heavily in the first halloween
which was again a teaser for what john
carpenter would go on to work on by
observing the way they died the druids
believed they could see omens of the
future
two thousand years later we've come no
further
samhain isn't
evil spirits
it isn't goblins ghosts or witches
it's the unconscious mind
we're all afraid of the dark inside
ourselves we're all afraid of the dark
inside of ourselves the idea that i've
come back to throughout this entire
video the idea that lori knows in her
subconscious that michael myers is her
brother is the terrifying reality of
this halloween night a reality that
makes even evil spirits goblins ghosts
and witches seem tame by comparison the
idea is hammered home by the final scene
bringing the story full circle lori is
right back where she started moving on
to yet another hospital the ambulance
disappears into what looks like a foggy
dreamscape the news station wwar who we
heard the initial reports from about
michael myers is now on the scene
getting coverage of his latest sets of
victims michael lies face down on the
ground seemingly defeated once more and
the song that takes us into the end
credits is none other than the song we
heard when this nightmare began mr
sandman bring me a dream this ending was
meant to be the death of michael myers
but as we now know the character was
just too profitable to stay dead however
the next halloween movie focuses on a
completely different story earning it
the title of black sheep of the
halloween franchise another big thanks
to jimmy champagne for breaking down the
sequel with me thanks again for having
me on zach i usually talk about new news
related to the halloween franchise so
it's always nice to go back and look at
where it started i'd like to tell you to
go subscribe to his channel but legally
i'm just not allowed to but i think just
between you and me
you know what to do so join us in the
next episode of things you missed as the
season rolls over and we discuss
halloween three season of the week
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring that death
bell for all notifications and i'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive
samhain